when life is tough says there is nothing
more soothing than delicate clay
for years he's made Iraqi traditional
pottery using centuries-old methods
he says his family has been in the
business for decades but it's coming to
an end
because of imports and a lack of demand
for our products and the lack of
government subsidized fuel our business
has been declining my family members and
cousins have changed their profession
Pottery is deeply rooted in Iraq's
ancient past
families carried out the profession from
generation to another for millennia
using the same ancient techniques to
turn mud into kitchenware and balls
these newly made puts and pictures need
to be left in the Sun for a few days
until they're dried up they are then put
here into this oven to be heated at
about 1500 degrees Celsius
for about 20 hours
today some families in the countryside
still use Clayton doors for baking
but the market is being overwhelmed by
cheaper puts imported from Iran
experts say Iraq's Heritage of Sumerian
and Babylonian Pottery manufacturing has
now become more of an art practiced in
Academia
in Iraq dates back to 4500 BC it was
linked to spiritual rituals in the 1950s
artists started introducing pieces
imitating ancient urns and murals
Pottery is part of Iraq's cultural
heritage so even if it declines as a
profession it still flourishes as
folklore throughout history Pottery has
provided households with not only useful
products
but also an archive of people's way of
life in ancient times
Safari's Factory has survived in an area
where dozens of others have been
abandoned yet he is the last one in his
extended family left holding on to a
profession that is thousands of years
old